It's get curious not
furious. And I think what's
interesting about this,
which is, you know, how
do you stay in that
curiosity space is that
that applies whether you're
avoidant or whether you
tend to kind of go
nought to 100.
Because if you're someone
that goes nought to 100,
we're saying notice that
you've got that you're
getting furious.
Just suspend judgement.
You know, if you need
to, if that means
you need to walk away
from this conversation
until you're in a better
place, fine, do that.
Prioritise that. Or can you
just go, I've noticed I'm
getting furious to kind of
start to own the feelings
and sort of get out
of that amygdala hijack in
that moment and then go,
what's my prepared question
that will just at least
announce that I'm curious
and get into this thing.
So, but also if we're
avoidant and we're
thinking,
what will they say if
I share my true thoughts
right now? What if you
were just getting curious?